but i don't know if i'm asking for too
much when i'm about to ask you next no
no no are you sure bro i know you're a
big wwe
fan yeah yeah and you did mention macho
man randy savage
oh
[Music]
what's up everybody you guys welcome to
this episode of hot boxing with mike
tyson i am your co-host aka
triple c henry cejudo and i'm mike tyson
and we got a special guest here mr david
arquette what's up brother what's up man
how you doing man what have you been
loving it come on
yeah location baby elsa gundam
yeah airport action so come on dave what
you been up to man
oh man i've been up to a lot i uh
just did a bunch of wrestling for the
last couple years oh and i did a
wrestling
documentary yeah you cannot kill david
arquette
yeah okay do we have some footage of
that they probably can you can find it
yeah let's check this [ __ ] out [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that's my heart anderson right
uh no not on anderson though
mr anderson oh he don't give a [ __ ]
about you dave
something happened
yeah so i upset the wrestling community
for 20 years
cause i i won the championship turn this
up guys
please i tried so this was back in uh
you were
was this a wcw yeah yeah that's
oh [ __ ]
oh that sounded that hurt
you actually did the stuff yeah man
i've wrestled on the streets of tijuana
you look good thanks man you're teaching
t.a you look good thanks man
if anxiety is
yeah it's hardcore man the mickey rockin
fighting near the [ __ ]
little [ __ ] yeah right here i see it
that's me singing
the wrestling master you really you
really had a uh
you had to go to wrestling classes and
all the above right like yeah
how long was how was that process pretty
peter avalon was an amazing
wrestling wrestler and and coach he
coached me
it was uh it was a really
incredible experience man i toured with
rj city right there
wow that was king of anthony
baby yeah man i imagine everybody trying
to kill you too
yeah that guy's gonna i don't know if he
was trying to but i do
i did i got cut in the neck with a light
tube and nearly died
this [ __ ] out now yeah yeah it's on uh
hulu
anywhere you could you could get it at
amazon and dan tell us about that what
happened
you got hit with the light point your
neck what how deep was that pain right
now it hit my neck muscles how about how
you feel this moment right now
no i feel pretty good man i feel pretty
good it kind of rests
all the wrestling i don't know it it
gives you certain injuries that
you just kind of feel all the time like
uh
so that was a death match i really i
didn't really know what i was getting
into
but uh yeah so it's a it's an
interesting journey though
uh david darg and price james were the
directors they did a great job my wife
christina produced it with xtr
you ever watched that extreme
championship wrestling when it's like
real that banging needle
nails in your head yeah yeah that's
that's the same stuff that's
one guy i think the black guy he went to
jail he didn't kill somebody in the seat
yeah he just passed yeah he passed away
too right well
yeah new jack was a crazy [ __ ]
yeah
hey let's look at new jack projections
oh he was awesome he was a crazy man he
was oh look at this [ __ ]
he is look at this [ __ ] man look at this
[ __ ] man
watch this real deal man then he killed
this guy
his father or something they sued them i
remember they sued them
what do you what do you mean mike's uh
did he kill somebody in the ring
yeah this is real stuff there's no fake
at all this is real
sam may you know him yeah sam man
he saved me you know at house of
hardcore in philadelphia during my
wrestling run
he came in which was pretty awesome and
then they surely
look at that [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ]
those are going from scars man
what kind of dress he's a method he was
a mess to come ahead or something
yeah who look at this this is how the
guy's gone
no this is real this is not fake yeah
henry henry don't tell me he's a jumper
look at this guy handy handy he's hit
henry watching his handy
[ __ ] no way and he's gonna throw the
[ __ ] off andy
no that's like 60 feet dude
[Applause]
that's the kind of [ __ ] i'm telling you
man man look man
that's crazy [ __ ]
what kind of [ __ ] is this damn
i'm so happy you knew who i was talking
about because i because you you just
have to see this guy
daddy
oh this is i'm not even there that's
gotta be 50 60 feet
and i think his father got mad to kick
before the sun happened
i don't know but i know this [ __ ] was
crazy
yeah they had a previous fight before
that something happened that was a
very severe receipt
now with the wrestlers thanks guys
that's something that you picture that's
kind of like a sequence what happened
back in 2000 the wcw so yeah
your passion for wrestling for so they
hated me for 20 years so i just wanted
to sort of
prove to the wrestling fans and just
sort of do a
love letter to wrestling so it's just a
journey it did it for
a while ken anderson was the guy you
mentioned
but i imagine you probably had your
heroes on who'd you have your hero
oh yeah well through the process of the
film i realized that
i loved macho man but i really loved
miss elizabeth
this elizabeth was like i like um and
then we realized my wife looks just like
her
when i was younger i like mill massacres
yeah
like bruno san martina he was my
champion moon dog maine
peter um pedro morales i remember killer
kowalski don leo
jonathan that's my thing give me fly you
don't know why
wrestling anymore not as much but you
know that's not true i do
but it's just not like before when i was
dying for every if it was on i wasn't
going anywhere
damn it i was just freaked out so mike
did you find
did you did you find boxing did you
start watching boxy first or wrestling
wrestling wrestling that's why i love
all that [ __ ] they be talking [ __ ]
and playing man i love doing that
oh that's the best
like this before baby i'm beautiful babe
i made it happen baby
[Music]
for you david like it's something that i
i you know cause
either way man how were you inspired to
be an actress i know you come from a
family full of actors was that something
that
was a competitive household huh well no
it wasn't really so competitive it's
just dramatic it's like we grew up all
of my
uh siblings were actors so it was like
comedy and tragedy every day every
minute
roller coasters making people laugh was
like
a win or making people cry you know
it was a lot of fun a lot of it was it
was just crazy
that was a lot of love what was your
mom's like oh my mom was amazing she uh
she had a really like uh interesting
trajectory she uh
was born in scranton pennsylvania was
like
yes town one of the uh
young jewish girl and one of the only
families in the in the area and
it was just sort of hard for her she got
abused as a kid and she
grew up tough and she uh met my dad in
new york
she was like a cheesecake she well she
was an actress but then she did some
cheesecake modeling
like the like nudie pictures and i had
found some when i was 18.
and i was looking through this book
because i always loved betty page and
i found my mom naked in the shower and
then four pages later
she's having a cat fight with another
girl in lingerie
and i'm like mom i've i found you in
this book
i am a 50s pinup and she i showed her
the picture she said
oh you know we weren't really fighting
i was like i know mom but look you're in
the shower your titties are out what's
going on
she was like well you know i you know i
was a young mother i had to pay
bills you know but it was artistic it
was supposed to you know they were
supposed to be artistic yeah in your
family was it like huge
uh was it like a legacy thing to you
know sometimes you know as
uh with fighters typically their sons
into boxing and things like that
did you feel that something very much a
little bit
i really had a great teacher named ben
debaldo in high school who really kind
of
changed the you know direction of my
life i was
doing graffiti and running around and
kind of getting in trouble and then
these girls told me there was a school
play and
i got to know this teacher ben de baldo
and then
we did this like it was called southern
california teachers association
like competition where everybody did
little things but it was all anonymous
and i'd always had like you know i knew
my family was i didn't know if i had any
talent or not
but then ben really sort of inspired me
and worked with me and i had this
monologue
and i came in second place at everyone
in the you know
southern california so it proved to me
that i had something and then
sort of gave me the confidence so the
next oh like just soon after that i had
an audition i got my first job right out
of high school
yeah so that was like your first big
break no no no
i don't care how much money they have
they're always looking for a gig
yeah it's the worst thing that's
something
yeah it's horrible
oh man it's so rough there's a lot of
rejection in the business
it's just like no matter what level
you're at
do you think even as a boxer mike do you
think like you felt like when you became
a world champion at 19 did you want
you did you just want to continue to
keep making more history looking for the
next fight
is that why you kind of say that mike or
i don't know i guess
i i got um addicted to the applause
yeah yeah you understand that for sure
yeah but um i
i equate it a lot to like when when
there's a baby you're like oh look at
the baby the baby
how he's come baby everyone look how
cute the baby baby gets a little older
and gets a little
and there's a new baby thing to get rid
of the baby like look at the baby
but everyone's looking for that original
baby like
oh everyone just wants to be loved you
know hopefully if that baby gets it
everybody wants love that's what it's
all
consists of this whole universe consists
of love
that's the that's the true currency of
life that's what all this
madness that's going on all this madness
is about it doesn't even appear that way
but that's what it's all about
i was thinking the other day so it's all
connected i love like fractals
and like the fibonacci sequence and like
the golden mean like those kind of
theories and it's all like we're all
sort of part of something else like it's
all connected
and i was thinking like so like if we're
well you know
we all have that light inside us but uh
you know we're not god we're part of
whatever
god is but god's also as good as good
and as evil as evil so you know
everything is everything right
so i was thinking if we are part of that
then we're like little cells
what kind of cells are we going to be
are we going to be little cancer cells i
think
are we going to be white blood cells
that are going to help
yeah whatever the hell's going on here i
look at i look at a
you know since my experience in life i
look at this as
um fungus you're funny i always think
like if all
if all the um the bees in the world die
the world will probably come to them if
all the
the dolphins die you know i mean the
world that if all the people died the
world would flourish
what fungus we cause diseases and all
that [ __ ] yeah
guys we just we just believe that we're
smarter than all the other animals so
it's okay there's an electronic circuit
fungus are all talking to each other
right now right now
yeah [ __ ] man there's a vibe and
well that's it imagine if everything
that you learned you didn't know
what was who would you be all the
information that you got since the day
you were born
and if you didn't know that information
who would you be
would you be just nothing would you
exist i think i think there's a
difference between like living and
existing i think we just be existing
rather than living
right i think that's why we we we don't
exist we have to we have to live because
we have to evolve
yeah that's what this stuff is all about
evolving to the level where we love each
other everybody
and we no longer hurt each other yeah
what's your take on that
david from what mike's saying that's it
man that's the whole game
you know yeah
i was like i don't know
losing friends recently and stuff and
losing my parents and
i was always thinking and it goes back
to the the kid thing i was thinking
about because i was one
time holding my son and his ah man i
wish
my mother and father could have met him
yeah and then i had this overwhelming
feeling like they were right there
they're looking through my eyes they
were
looking back from it was just this from
from his eyes
yeah it was all like we're still here
like in this weird like
it was this moment like i don't know
so that it it's all connected a lot of
the movies man i i grew up i watched you
scream
never never been kissed man how was it
man working uh
working with drew barrymore man like how
was that whole process man
she's an incredible incredible woman
she's so great
yeah and it was amazing we had been
friends we all kind of grew up in
in hollywood so you know she's family
you know what i mean
like just love her with all my heart
then um
getting to play your brother and then
it's just like
wow you ever met marlon brando i worked
with marlon brando yeah
i did on his final film that was a
really
humbling and beautiful experience he was
a
like a hero i think he's
just you don't even have to i was so
scared you have to know what he do but
the name itself is just bigger than life
when when he passed i was kind of sad
that he wasn't honored more you know
what i mean it wasn't
like i don't know no he was the arch
enemy against um
the music academy yeah for sure and he
was really
you know he was talking early on about
what's going on now and
recognizing our mistakes of the past and
not sweeping them under the rug so we
can deal with them and face them and
and like then understand you know
everything that's going on now people
are like you're
it's my heritage it's like yeah well
like
i don't get it because
it's just so far we go all we go so back
in time that we're all related
that's that's what it is man that's what
i feel there's nothing more powerful
than time
it's it's almost like this right mike
it's like we all
you know there's faith there's there's
religion
there's you know cultures but in reality
don't you guys feel like at times it's
like we just come from the
the human race man like we are all we
all come from the same branches like
we're no different than that tree
on the earth we're a product of earth
yes but still
i always wonder what do the birds call
us what are we to know what
you know what do the rats call us what
do our dogs call us do they call us
humans no they must
i wonder what do they call us always
wanted to know that what the animals
call us
we call them birds or dogs i wonder what
do they call us
there's so many billions of animals
right insects and stuff
and they all have a different opinion
about us isn't that something
that the billions and trillions of ants
and bugs and birds
they all have a different opinion about
us who we are different names
yeah so when pull billions of things
if you look at it from that perspective
yeah interesting
if you look at a x-ray of a lung
and you look at the silhouette of a tree
it's like an identical it's identical
and it's like
that's that's what it is that's some
deep stuff like that
stuff like that it makes me think live
so long
why do they yeah some of them live over
200 years
yeah probably even longer to use
that's been us i love the redwoods are
like my favorite
yeah going up to the redwoods there's
something super humbling about that
it's a different energy i've never been
there but i've always wanted to go it's
the house
have you been there before mike no but
i've been up to the alps before and
that's very humbling
the alps yeah french alps so there's a
place called reggie on the river
up in like humboldt county oh that
concert
we head over we used to go when we were
like
you know the end of high school 17 or
something
yeah it was amazing it's a great
breaking concert
yeah i saw i saw you bring up the fact
that you you brought
you do you have a newborn uh no i'm a
four-year-old a seven-year-old
four-year-old and fourth pretty newborn
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's pretty
awesome for you though
how has that changed your perspective
obviously you've done some amazing
things in acting
you know being in hollywood getting
getting the chance to see
life as a whole man like i imagine the
experience of having a kid yeah such a
young age
yeah it brings up a lot of [ __ ] man we
had a so my mom
she had an abusive childhood so she in
turn was
abusive to the kids like growing up and
it was kind of
we all had to come to terms with that
and figure that out and
you know heal ourselves but her great
story is that then she went to
college and did all this internship and
and hours and got her degree as a
marriage family counselor
and she was on her death bed with with
breast cancer and i said mom it's like
you
graduated from life you know you did it
you stopped the cycle
yeah so that was pretty beautiful moment
you know
yeah it's uh but yeah so kids it totally
changes your life
but you do have to deal with those
things you know
my dad was a rager so i find myself
especially during this pandemic i was
raising my voice and
but you know i had to figure out how not
to lose my [ __ ] you know
just because because my little one was
then getting scared and like
and then you feel horrible your kid but
sometimes you do want to scare your kid
so you don't fall off the
second floor of that thing you know what
i mean but it's almost like you're a
product
you're a product of your past but it's
almost like you have to make sure
and correct me if i'm wrong go for it
like that you're a product of your past
but you you got to make sure
you don't become a prisoner of it yeah
you can't listen dictate your future
oh yeah man i really just think about
saying that's the story of the life our
past dictates our future
don't care how small and sophisticated
we are yeah
it takes deep working on yourself to get
over that kind of condition
i've read this thing on sanskrit and it
said
there are no mistakes there's only
lessons no no mistake there's only
lessons no accidents and you'll repeat
the lessons
until you get them figure it out and
there will always be lessons
i believe life is destiny and then
that's sometimes how i feel too mike and
obviously obviously you know mike
like you you well i'm not gonna look for
trouble i'm gonna run into trouble but
you know i'm gonna use my brain
by living your life by your instincts i
think it's destiny
yeah it's almost like this too mike you
you obviously you've been to prison mike
you know what i'm saying
there's a lot of good people in prison
but they just decided to [ __ ] up that
one time they just made a bad choice
and now they're [ __ ] doing life i
know some really beautiful people in
there
that did some really bad things but you
can't tell these people
in the free world this guy that murdered
certain amount of people because some
people said though
is a nice guy because they don't have
they're not spending five years with
this guy every day every moment of the
of five years
so they're not gonna understand your
reasoning with them
so would you say sometimes it's the luck
of the luck of the dice like
that split second can change everything
no it's all about our decisions and
about destiny
and about how how much we can endure
endurance is what life is pretty much
about what do you think david what do
you think about that
as an actor man what you've been through
think about what you had to do though i
don't know
this is the man man you lost family
members
yeah yeah you know that's a that's a lot
of it you know what i mean
and he can't do it in private the whole
world has to see it too
you know he can't do it in private
everywhere he goes somebody's gonna save
i'm sorry to hear this or this everybody
knows his business
in a way i don't prefer it but i
i don't like like secrets and i try to
be
i try to learn from my mistakes and you
know i try to like be honest
you know there's some things i've you
know done and i'm not happy about
you know what i mean i used to always go
to strip clubs you know what i mean
i had to deal with that you know let me
know
listen the other people in us you know
what i mean have did the strip clubs man
that don't mean
nothing bad about you no no of course of
course and i
do love trica but uh um i don't know
just uh
uh there's just the more you go on you
figure out
it starts becoming a little clearer like
what what makes me feel
good you know what i mean oh i'm getting
angry what's that feeling from
where's it coming from why am i and then
if you can get a second where you can
not react to it like that's that's one
of my big things
right i'm not beating myself up this is
actually funny
i've been thinking like you know i had a
teacher that
used to put me up in front of class and
make me read and
i couldn't read really well and i had
dyslexia and i'd go through it and i was
like
it was horrifying like and she'd always
do it
and it was just it made me feel so dumb
so i got went through my whole life
thinking i was dumb and then i just beat
myself up beat myself up and then i like
realized this i'm like oh but now since
i realized that
i stepped back then i can see i am
actually pretty dumb
there's also some some beauty and
ignorance sometimes i'm just like
being not not dumb but just
just right now you're gonna
youngest heavyweight champ of all
speaking about smoking man you got a new
movie here coming out with snow oh yeah
yeah
this is something i'm really good about
what's the name of it it's called
domino battle of the bones roll it
oh man let's roll you see i'm so excited
about this
it's just so fun
talking in our body i know there's a lot
of [ __ ] in us
[Laughter]
oh
that guy's great so is lou baby jr
you put some crazy [ __ ] in the
movie yeah
baron davis director everybody yeah yeah
oh bad it's beautiful man yeah dominoes
battle the bones yeah it's just a fun
movie
my wife who really doesn't care about my
acting career she just never really
showed any interest she can't wait and
once you lose
this you'll never stop doing this yeah i
imagine man
would your kids want to fall into the
same footsteps as you
my my daughter she loves to sing and act
so i i don't know it kind of is in their
blood i gotta say
yeah but it's a rough business i mean
not you know everything's relative
but and i imagine and i imagine again
you could be p
you can keep it pg-13 here but imagine
how crazy was there
was those damns parties man especially
when you're younger and obviously
oh no you're a lot more i don't know if
you're right yeah
yeah yeah it was crazy growing up in in
l.a in hollywood
you know i got my first job when i was
17 so it's kind of like then i made my
own money
and then uh and then it never happens
but the pilot i did got picked up to a
series
then we went on for 13 episodes so i i
i was right in like just learning how to
do it all
would you mind having your kids that
have that same lifestyle that's a
question for you too mike
we've purposely kept our daughter like
not like there's
been casting directors or people you
know what i mean but we've just been
like
not until you're older until you can
make your own decisions about what
you know so it's not not a kid kid
acting's just such a
amazing if there's a kid who's so driven
that he just doesn't take no for an
answer i get that
too but yeah my our daughter
understood i think that's good because
that brings in balance
i'm the same way pretty much i want them
to be happy in what they're doing
yeah but but would you wish them to go
through the same stuff that you went
through as a boxer
would you would you encourage that
you know what i'm saying could you see
would you want your kids to go something
that you've gone through
well i don't want them to go now i want
one to go my route even as a world
champion
yeah i wouldn't want them to go my route
no i wouldn't want them to do that
because i
i'm like um i beat myself up
a lot i can't i can't i can't i can't be
nice to myself
i'll i'll take it easy too easy i might
party too much i got to be
disciplined totally disciplined and say
get your fat ass off the couch and get
out and
my run i beat me up baby yeah
is that how that was that how your uh
your last fight with roy jones jr mike
were you uh
you're a discipline as hell yeah a 54
year old man dude mike would get up
every single morning cause i talked to
rob
every single morning mike was always up
he would do his miles dude i'm just like
god lee i
you know what i'm saying i'm i'm i'm
young but if i start
slacking up and look eating a little too
much about my um
my subconscious watch is fat ass
you know how they should watch your fat
ass it's gonna be hard to get in those
pretty soups with your fat ass eating
that cheesecake
i love that your voice is
why don't you try to put that so i'm
just trying to keep
reminding myself to change that voice to
there is something where you so this one
book called
love yourself like your life depends on
it really helped me
by uh i think it's camille rivkin or
something
but it's it's sexy you end up just
meditating to do it i love myself i love
myself
into the mirrors though email kuwei the
first
um what do you call that apparition
effort affirmation guy
oh really say i believe myself day by
day and everyone being better i'm a
guard i'm a warrior of well you know
it's it's just
this it helps though because it creates
that
improve in your brain so you give that
group
strength so whenever you go to the
negative group that that voice should
say oh
you know what i have i love myself group
and i don't know it got me out of some
like really depressing situations
because
you know if you see uh the documentary
it's really sort of
open yeah man the new uh your new
documentary man tell us about that
oh yeah so you know
it's out there already i mean it was a
journey i do
ketamine in it like throughout the
doctor's office make you feel ken
doctor's office i did it with the doctor
and then uh
they did a do you white out the
conscience so there's
one where they do it intravenously and
then you just pass out which is in the
movie but you see me
a little bit before i go under but
the other way is by iv still and then
in the doctor's office but then you have
a therapy session
so it's just trippy because you're
having a therapy session
you know and it's a dissociative
anesthetic
so it essentially takes your like
separates you from your ego more
yeah so then you're starting to deal
with stuff and then i had this thing
where i was thinking about my
relationship
and my parents relationship and my then
i started thinking about my parents
relationship and i was turbulent i was
feeling all this heaviness
and then it occurred to me they're both
dead and i was like
god bless you and i love you but you're
gone so let's
let's lift that too like i don't need
your
marriage like pain anymore you know and
that actually freed me up a little
i don't know who knows what any of this
stuff works i'm just trying to
figure it out yeah did you did you have
a did you have a mentor
growing up there's somebody that you can
be like hey that's my
that's the person that really made the
biggest impact in my life did you have a
person like that
yeah i think you meet like a lot of
people along the way
these journeys yeah maybe a lot of
people brothers
we're just passing through brother we're
just passing through yeah my brother
richman was in
alexis i shared a room with alexis who
was my transgender
brother and sister yeah you know it's
it's
complicated because you know turned into
my sister but then at the end of
her life she said i want you to refer to
me as your brother
so i sort of do it talking like during
time periods
but that was her thing i think now she's
saying she's more fluid you know what i
mean no
2021 you be who the [ __ ] you want to be
yeah
exactly how how was your your life
growing up with
you mentioned your sister man huh how
was that oh
did you always know that growing up that
uh or was this revealed later in her
life when she was at a certain age
no my sister rosanna who like ran away
uh moved out to l.a stayed with the
family a
friend of our family whatever but then
um
she uh she likes got into the acting
game
like you know went to an open call and
there's some wild story about her
sitting in a casting office
for this word she saw these girls going
in and out and the cast director's
coming in and out
and then they said what's your name uh
we don't have any more appointments and
she said oh i don't have an appointment
you started to walk out and she
went on the ground and started doing an
epileptic
seizure and they all freaked out and had
and then
she had got up and she was acting
because the role enacted
asked for someone with a epileptic
seizure and that
they she got the role that was like one
of her first things
she really paved the way for the second
generation so my dad was an actor for 40
years 45 years
my grandfather was an actor named uh
cliff arquette who was
charlie weaver who was on the original
tonight show and and old
um uh hollywood squares he was the old
old man in the corner so it's sort of in
my and it always
goes all the way back to vodka do you
ever think you know the purpose of it
yeah i think i well to stay real
to be real like to whatever role you're
doing
like real so that you connect with
people
and whichever role you're playing within
that story that you help them feel
you help maybe like help people see
something from a different angle or
feel emotions about stuff connect like
my thing is like when you
connect as an actor and you're you're
are you real and you feel like
you're no longer honest yeah do you feel
like you could like you could meet
somebody and then you could examine him
for a certain amount of time and then
you could like um
become him
a little bit some a little bit all right
johnny's here and we did uh sherlock
holmes together like
it was like a sort of comedic take on
sherlock holmes and that was the first
experience it was just so hard
that i was like oh sometimes you're not
right for a certain role
you know what i mean you have to be like
for that specific role that
i personally think you have to be
english to play
him but i don't know and james bond
who's your favorite actor
of all time uh of all times i
love peter sellers for comedy i loved
marlon brando
and james dean for trauma and
you know i i tended a little like like
oh but uh robert de niro like
the time period of uh the scorsese films
he was doing
and mel gibson i like bill gibson a lot
yeah
guys i'm a fan of mel gibson i heard
that this man is one of the great people
yeah he's great i had an audition with
bob gibson one time and i'm so nervous
and i'm horrible in auditions this is
like i'm like this trying to play a role
and
i was like reading the scene i got up
like this
i turned around and i sat back down and
i kept reading this thing
i don't know why i didn't mean to get up
i was like
i don't know it was the most
embarrassing thing yeah mike mike who
are some of your greatest actors man you
met the world man mike who do you
uh who who are your top three actors of
all time
top five mikes i know you you got a
variety of them
oh man and they're too great
it relates to boxing too you know what
i'm saying like i'm i'm a um
i love bob de niro and al pacino
but i think bob um de niro is my actor
he's the
he's the energy
little girl yeah there's so many man
it's
daniel dave lewis is insane it's almost
like the same noah was good too
um citizen kang the guy who played that
awesome welt he did a good job on that
oh hell yeah he was insane
so dope yeah so some of the all times
great man what about uh
so you have uh you have screen five
coming out
uh is that is that that is that the uh
is that that wasn't done
i was in one of those one guys
scary movie scary movie yeah yeah yeah
that was the original title of the first
one
i'm not really allowed to talk about it
too much because there's just they're
lock us down but i love playing the role
of dewey it's so fun
yeah that's about all they're allowed
i'm a little disabled
yeah yeah now but doing the i mean it's
been amazing
what would you say the best advice that
was ever given to you
that uh that you can now kind of realize
and share
uh kindness from other people you know
what i mean
one that's the biggest lesson like
people mentors of mine who have been
kind to me
always telling me everyone remember to
be kind
remember to be kind
and i'm my mother
you're not my mother you're my wife yeah
it's true though right because you have
to because i'm sure like dude
i'm every time i'm around mike like you
know mike is he's a good sport man but i
can tell sometimes
you know it's hard you know what i'm
saying because he needs his privacy i
like just hanging out with my boy
yeah and people invade their space
so when you say when you bring up
kindness that means that you got to be a
good sport man you know what i'm saying
regardless
of patience yeah so that's you know if
we everyone gets pushed
you know what i mean everyone has bad
moments
but yeah you want to be kind especially
i had this whole thing where you know
i'm the greatest in my world
you know like muhammad ali used to say
i'm the greatest so i was like yes
and i'm the greatest like obviously the
everybody is the greatest in their world
you know what i mean you are the
greatest
right you know what i mean that's that's
you know i know
he was talking for yeah she's just the
biggest legend of all but i don't know
when i when i connect with
sports figures you know it's usually
from a place like
i want to yeah i want to be like them
that's why
when the wrestling thing happened you
know it's all kind of predetermined so
they were like
we're going to make you the champion i
was like that's a terrible idea because
you know i've never done that you know
i've been earned it
you know
as a kid i always wanted to hold the
belt up everybody wants to be the
champion everyone wants to be loved
you know so i was like yeah it sounds
like fun but i didn't know people get
something when i was
you know going through my problems in
rehab and i remember what was in chapter
four it says
and you're reading the book and it says
the causes of the major causes of
relapses is the lack of love and too
much of it
so it has to be some kind of balance you
know yeah
balance better to that effect this is
something else effect you know
so you could just be just being adorned
by people and they can just well if
that's good
how could that not be good you know but
you know
it's just not that way because
everything i remember when i was in the
program
every time people were happy because i
wasn't using i was miserable
and then when i was high i was happy
everybody in the house was missing
nobody's smiling you know that feeling
right
you happy you took it around
[Laughter]
you look real stupid you really you're
gonna die you're gonna i'm gonna give
you a real fly funeral
it's telling me [ __ ] i just i don't want
to hit it i want to enjoy my high and
they got to hear all this [ __ ]
negativity in my mind
right you're over here you're over there
buzzing right now
everybody [ __ ] damn depressed face at
me oh
[ __ ] can i look at laura order
and leave me the [ __ ] alone
[ __ ] with me oh no what what's next
uh david for your for you and your
career what's what's
what's the next big thing that you would
that's that's got coming up with you
i'm gonna do new documentaries soon
which will be
you know something i've been dreaming
about since i was really young so it's
been a long
like thing and it's about love it's
about laughter and it's about
sort of you know just
that we're all connected so that's what
i'm
sort of working on it's a beast though
these projects are beasts but also we
started a
documentary comp uh company called xtr
which is now one of the leading uh
nonfiction
studios for documentaries doing some
beautiful did over 40 documentaries
eight in
sundance last year so it's a thing then
we
with with them we started uh documentary
plus
which you can go to doc plus.com
and uh it's a free streaming service for
hundreds of like super high
like curated some academy award-winning
werner herzog
all these incredible documentary
filmmakers
so we did this documentary plus so that
people had a place they could go
it's not another service you have to
sign up for it's literally like uh
something you could get on roku yeah
it's pretty dope that's what's up dude
that's what's
like to help art you know what i mean
literally the point of it is like to i
know curate art like and
just help people be able to see cool
movies
yeah that's awesome uh mike what uh what
advice do you have for david
originally yeah as you know um
always forgive yourself don't hold
grudges against yourself
and just um do the best
possible to be happy you know and that's
that's all sometimes
in the moment sometimes when it's in the
moment it goes so fast
you know it's your life is just about
the moments the moments because life is
just a blink of an
eye then it's over thanks chad
link to the eye that's awesome man man
well on that note
i really uh it's david it's been awesome
dude but i don't know if i'm asking for
too much when i'm about to ask you next
no
no no are you sure bro i know you're a
big wwe
fan yeah yeah and you did mention macho
man randy savage
[Applause]
baby
[Laughter]
damn damn we're about to break the
internet
that's what's up man well that's been
your show today here at hopbox and i am
your co-host
aka triple c henry cejudo and i'm mike
tyson this is my man
mr david david love yourself
we are all day
[Music]
you